ومن العراق الى لبنان الذي فشل في انتخابي
رئيسه للجلسه السابعه على التوالي الجسر
الذي يربط ايران ابي معقل الوكيل والشريك
حزب الله وهنا طرق ايران في الالتفاف لا
تنفذ وهذه المره رماسيه الظل هي الوسيله
القناصل الفخريون هم من يقومون بوظيفه
القنصل عن الدوله في مناطق ليس لها تمثيل
دبلوماسي مواطنون عاديون يمنحون
امتيازاتهن اديبلوماسيه وبذلك لا قيود لا
مصادره لارشيفات ولمراسلات ولا تفتيش
متعلقاتها هذه هي الحيله التي استخدمها
حزب الله لتنفيذي هدف ايراني عمليته غسل
اموال وتهريب والعائدات لمن الاجابه
معروفه الكشف كان بتحقيقنا ان نشرت
تفاصيله صحيفه
500 قنصل فخريا حاليا وصادق متهمون بهذه
الجرائم لكن ارتباطهم بجماعات ارهابيه هو
اللافت حزب الله في الصوره طبعا او لنقل
هو الصوره
منذ عام 2008 بوجوهنا كثيره بعضها مكشوف
محمد ابراهيم والمطلوب للولايات المتحده
كان قنصلا فخريا متورطا بجرائم غسل
الاموال غير المشروعه من خلال الشركاته في
لبنان وافريقيا وكان مستوردا للبترول في
جامبيا وشريكا نقل الرئيسي انا باك يحي
جامح قائمته الاسماء المتورطه ايضا تطول
من بينها رجل اعمال اللبناني يدعى عالم
ميري عيانه جنوب السودان فخريا في لبنان
قبض عليه عام اثناء قيمته
بملايين الدولارات
وتحويل العائدات الى حزب الاحد
[موسيقى]